[ Beeping ]
-Let's a-go.
[ Kart engine revs ]
-Whoo!
♪♪
-I am a massive fan
of "Last of Us."
Obviously, I love "Mario Kart."
And this is sort
of a spiritual sequel
to the sketch Streeter Seidell
and I did called
"Grouch," which was marrying
Oscar the Grouch with Joker.
So this is "The Last of Us"
meets "Mario Kart."
You have Mario and Luigi,
Pedro Pascal as Mario.
-Grazie mille.
Whoo-hoo!
-Whoo-hoo!
You have Princess Peach,
the equivalent of Ellie
in this.
-I think this is gonna
be a show.
Put it on Peacock.
-And then you have Kenan
as Bowser.
-I'm an actor.
I'm a professional.
I mean, there you go.
You could just put
a camera on Kenan.
-Action.
-We're on the set of our
post-apocalyptic "Mario Kart"
trailer, thing.
Every time I show up on set
and see what everyone
put together, it's always
mind-blowing.
-Starting with the biggest set,
we're calling it
the Mario Track.
-It definitely needs the patches
of grass and asphalt.
There's a refugee camp
where they all live.
-When they meet Luigi,
it's this crazy haunted mansion.
We don't outright
say it's Luigi Mansion,
but I think folks familiar with
Mario lore will put it together.
There's a lot of little
Easter eggs.
That has got to be one
of the most ambitious
pre-tapes I would say.
Me and the DP, Lance,
shot the entire car chase
with toy cars and a go-kart,
just to kind of wrap
our heads around how
it's going to play out
and also give to the post team
so we're all on the same page.
-And turn.
♪♪
[ Tires squealing ]
[ Both screaming ]
-We have an incredible post team
at 30 Rock
who collaborated
with crazy talented
VFX artists from all over
the country
who are working non-stop
from Wednesday
right to up air, Saturday.
We used 3D scans of the cast
and the cars,
a lot of digital set extensions,
and some scenes
were just full CG.
We're excited. I mean,
you get to be a kid again.
Whoo-ho-ho-ho!
-If you're watching this,
I guess we pulled it off.
[ Laughs ]
-That's a wrap on Pedro!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was great.